[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine foot ball trap a raté le
coche ce week-end en championnat de
régionale 2 les trappistes se sont
inclinés 2 1 à domicile contre suresnes
le résumé du match dans ce magazine
football zoom sur clément chantôme
l'ancien joueur du psg est aujourd'hui
l'un des piliers du club de l'ès fois ci
nous l'avons rencontré à l'entraînement
reportage à suivre mm à coups de
projecteurs aujourd'hui sur le sdc
health center la structure basée à
maurepas pratiques notamment le mma à
haut niveau ce sera notre module
découverte l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ce titre on va
parler de boxe cela rassurez-vous tony
hawk à combattre à bien le 15 janvier
prochain l'accord hôtel arena de paris
bercy mais les vinoy n'affrontera
finalement pas carlos takam blessé au
poignet le boxeur de
chanteloup-les-vignes défiera le
congolais martin bacot les jeux sportifs
et 18e mondiale il mesure 1 m 98 il
affiche un bilan de 17 victoires pour
une défaite il a souvent fait office de
sparring partner aux poids lourds
anthony joshua tony hawk eye quant à lui
toujours invaincu et il est classé 20e
mondiale on continue par du football
dans le championnat de régionale 2
trappe peau rate le coche d'être happy
se sont inclinés 2 1 sur leur pelouse
contre suresnes le résumé du match des
images de mélanie poké un match pour
monter sur le podium trappe et suresnes
deux équipes du top 5 de régional de
s'affronter ce dimanche 12 décembre
après un début de match équilibré la
défense trappistes est prise de vitesse
et concèdent l'ouverture du score des
locaux n'arriveront pas à marquer 1-0 à
la pause ça a été très compliqué mais
effectivement on n'est pas rentré dans
les meilleures conditions on a concédé
l'ouverture du score sur une erreur de
notre part comme comme la semaine
dernière alfortville et ça nous a mis un
peu la tête dedans et après on a été un
peu déstabilisé on n'a pas été
complètement
complètement sûr de ce qu'on faisait et
voilà malheureusement on rentre aux
vestiaires avec le 1-0 en seconde
période les trappistes monopolise le
ballon et se montrent offensifs pour
revenir au score ils se font punir sur
ce contre le break est fait pour sûr n 2
à 0 ne se démobilise pas sur cette
action le joueur de suresnes touche le
ballon de la main carton rouge et
penalty 2-1 malgré ce dernier coup-franc
trappe ne reviendra pas au score c'est
vrai que on a on en manquait beaucoup
beaucoup de jeu trouve de justesse
technique et pas forcément de juste
associés dans l'est dans les choix ou on
aurait pu faire de meilleures choses
c'est un match un peu compliqué avec une
équipe qui est venue me chercher bien
haut
après avec le terrain un peu difficile
on essaie de s'adapter comme on pouvait
c'est un match un peu compliqué mais on
va essayer de se rattraper même si on a
fait un bon résultat on essaie de se
rattraper cette quatrième défaite de la
saison est un coup d'arrêt pour les
trappistes dans la quête d'une place
dans le haut du classement les idées
noires restent cinquièmes prochain match
ce dimanche 19 décembre sur le terrain
de nanterre un adversaire direct
on va continuer à parler des autres
résultats sportifs du week-end dans les
yvelines avec bixente mais rien senti
cette balle qui nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau bonsoir bixente sans michael
alors trap a perdu ce week-end on l'a vu
précédemment mais ce n'est pas le cas de
tous les clubs yvelinois engagé en
régionale 2 puis avec l'équipe réserve
de poissy qui continue sa course en tête
de la poule après s'être imposé 3 0 sur
la pelouse du à ses lilas voici les
premiers donc après huit journées trappe
et 5e de la poule d et dans les poules
de la poule b justement quels sont les
résultats de matches nuls michael et le
même score 1 partout à chaque fois
leader du championnat où il a été arrêté
pour la première fois après sept matches
sans le fc tremblay il avait pourtant
enchaîné six victoires lors des six
premières journées c'est donc leur
premier petit ralentissement dans le
championnat mais pas de panique il reste
à trois points de leurs dauphins bobigny
avec un match en moins l'autre club
l'autre club c'est neauphle
pontchartrain tenu en échec à
franconville nov les 7e et présente un
bilan de 3 victoires 1 nul et 4 défaites
sajoo est aussi plus haut en nationale 2
ce week-end
il ya une fois n'est pas coutume pris le
meilleur sur son adversaire cette fois
c'est plabennec qui en a fait les frais
une victoire 2 1 en terre bretonne
versailles et donc dauphin de nationale
2 derrière la réserve de lorient quant
au pis y'a qui est moins bien embarqué
dans la division une défaite à la maison
face à vannes 3 1 voici et donc 11e on
ouvre notre page rugby à présent bixente
j avec la fédérale 2 où se trouve le
rugby-club de plaisir qui s'est incliné
contre sarcelles quatrième au classement
sur le score de 23 30 les plaisirs aux
as voit la première moitié de tableau
s'éloigner de congrès agir pour remonter
en deuxième partie de saison et
rejoindre au moins la 6e place synonyme
de qualification en phase finale un
poids un présent sur la fédérale 3 la
division qui réussit on peut le dire aux
yvelinois j'en aime bien en parler
toutes les semaines nickel on sait
lorsqu'on sait qu'il y aura forcément
des bonnes nouvelles et cette semaine
encore mieux le sourire exactement les
maisons laffitte et versailles ont
obtenu la victoire bonifiée pour les
leaders versailles une victoire 4,44 à
14 contre cergy pontoise et pour son
dauphin donc le mlsgp 56 25 contre caen
troisième du championnat ou y étaient
dispensées de matches ce week end un mot
de notre championne évinoise emilie
boulard à présent une récompense pour
l'arrière yvelinoise du quinze de france
celle de l'essai féminin de l'année par
l'international rugby player c'était le
3 avril dernier face au pays de galles
pour le premier match des six nations
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez vu donc avec son numéro 15
c'est exactement ce qu'on veut voir
rugby une action collective avec une
joueuse donc à l'origine et à la
conclusion et qui résiste aussi à deux
plaquages un essai à montrer dans toutes
les écoles michael est une récompense
bien méritée c'est magnifique on
continuera évidemment à la suivre en
2022 c'est émilie proulx la honte
termina par du basket mais en nationale
2 féminine la 11e journée avait lieu ce
samedi soir l'entente le
chesnay-versailles l'emporter 73 à 56 à
la maison contre le havre dernier de la
division à la fin des phases aller le
lcv est à la deuxième marche du podium
enfin côté garçons en nationale 3 trap a
vaincu le sait chartres 2,86 à 65 e
aussi termine la première partie de
saison en tant que dauphin du classement
et pour finir un petit mot de marly le
roi qui enchaîne une deuxième victoire
de suite contre barjouville les mains
les choix reviennent quasiment à la
hauteur de leurs concurrents de quoi
bien enchaîner lors de la deuxième
partie de saison puisqu'il était dernier
une deuxième partie de saison qui
débutera le 8 janvier prochain par la
réception de bezons juste devant être
appuyés raoult merci à bixente pour
toutes ces précisions vous retrouve
l'année prochaine en 2022 vous
continuerez à nous proposer chaque
semaine votre tour d'horizon des
résultats sportifs dans les yvelines
bonne fête bixente attention pas trop
d'excès 1 pendant les fêtes mais vous
connaissez bien et qu'elle vous savez
que c'est une période qui me réussit pas
trop en général mais je faire attention
on verra ça à la rentrée un en tout cas
alors eux aussi devront être sérieux
pendant les fêtes encore plus s'il
arrive à se qualifier en seizièmes de
finale de la coupe de france versailles
s'en va défier ce samedi 18 décembre le
club alsacien de l' us sarre-union en
32e de finale de la coupe de france les
versailles et seront favoris de cette
rencontre ils sont pour le moment à la
deuxième place du classement de
nationale 2 et sarre-union et dans le
ventre mou de nationale 3 la rencontre
sera à suivre à 13h45 sur les chaînes du
groupe eurosport lui aussi aurait bien
aimé poursuivre l'aventuré en coupe de
france mais son club poissy a été
éliminé par versailles et au tour
précédent à 34 ans à clément chantôme
est l'un des piliers de cette équipe de
l'as poissy qui évolue en nationale 2
avec son expérience il veut aider le
club à atteindre ses objectifs des
images de nicolas d'ombrie
son sens du placement et sa qualité de
passe ont ravi les spectateurs du parc
des princes entre 2006 et 2015
l'ancien parisien clément chantôme ou
foule aujourd'hui les terrains de
national 2 le joueur a rejoint l'as
poissy en 2020 après avoir arrêté sa
carrière pendant six mois c'est la
passion qui est qui reprend le dessus et
puis moi j'étais habitué depuis que j'ai
l'âge de 12 ans d'être enceinte
m'entraîne tous les jours et le fait
d'arrêter pendant six mois juste assez
jeunes beaucoup d'envié revenu depuis
clément chantôme joue régulièrement avec
l'équipe une de poissy le sportif de
transmettre son expérience acquise lors
de ses 300 matches passés sur les
pelouses de ligue 1 avec le psg toulouse
bordeaux et rennes c'est mon joueur le
plus régulier déjà acquis qu'il restait
des puits depuis la préparation il
restait à un niveau très intéressant et
il répète ces matches là donc c'est la
différence qu'il ya entre lui et les
autres joueurs après forcément c'est
beaucoup plus facile d'avoir clément
chantôme avec avec soi que contre
aujourd'hui le footballeur vtd poissy à
se maintenir en nationale 2 le club est
pour l'instant 11e sur cèze n'aurait pu
mieux faire parce que on a une équipe
qui joue très bien cette année ont je
pense que les résultats au fait même pas
le classement même si c est fait mieux
cette année on aurait peut-être encore
plus haut à 34 ans la motivation semble
toujours présente au plus grand bonheur
des spectateurs de national plus
on va maintenant prendre la direction de
plaisir mercredi après-midi avait lieu
au stade bernard giroux de plaisir la
signature d'une convention de
partenariat entre le fo plaisir et le
red star club professionnel évoluant en
national une signature qui s'est
déroulée en présence du directeur
sportif du club de saint-ouen steve
marlet ancien joueur passé par fulham en
angleterre lyon et marseille en france
il nous expliquait à l'intérêt de ce
partenariat il était au micro de bixente
mérian santisteva sur l'aspect sportif
c'est intéressant mais ça pas que c'est
aussi des échanges avec les éducateurs
nous le but c'est de
d'ouvrir le club à tous les départements
et de l'ouvrir à des clubs qui nous
ressemble qui ne ressentent dans la
dynamique de structuration c'est le cas
avec avec plaisir est dans l'adn
notamment ce qu'ils transmettent ce
qu'ils veulent transmettre aux jeunes ce
qu'ils font en dehors aussi du football
c'est une très grande fierté c'est vrai
que mon fils le restaure c'est un club
de la région parisienne le club
historique ça nous permettent de
continuer nos structures et
des nouvelles de louis burton à présent
le skipper souvenez-vous le skipper de
bas du bateau bureau vallée 3 du
navigateur et vino avait démâté alors
qu'il occupait la deuxième place sur la
transat jacques vabre 2021 incident
survenu en pleine nuit quelques heures
après le départ après plusieurs semaines
d'investigations la raison est désormais
connue louis burton a confié à nos
confrères de voiles et voiliers qu'un
câble de voix jitrois sûre et
responsable de la voirie le mas a pris
10 degrés de plus car ils n'étaient pas
retenues vers l'avant un système de
crochets n'aurait a pas fonctionné
d'après les premiers indices les équipes
de louis burton essaye désormais de
réparer au plus vite les dégâts pour
qu'il puisse revenir en mer le plus
rapidement possible les équipes de
bureau vallée parle du mois d'avril on
passe maintenant à notre coup de
projecteur de la semaine aujourd'hui tv
68 est allé du côté du sdcl senteurs de
maurepas une structure qui pratiquent
notamment le mma à haut niveau regardez
aujourd'hui nous sommes au sdcl center
de maurepas nous allons découvrir un
sport qui fait beaucoup parler lui le
mma
mais qui est ce qui est le cas pour ma
soeur pour nous
cette étape canon mais c'est le petit
stade
à mes côtés yann lamotte le directeur du
sdc elle center à laurianne qu'est ce
que ça veut dire sdcl center j'aimerais
qu'ils me posent la question vaut ce qui
s'appelle en fait tout le monde me la
posent
mais ça a évolué avec le temps en fait
elle décèle au départ c'est quand on
monte en arrière c'est le même âge était
interdite en france ou plutôt était pas
autorisée et pour faire du combat libre
il fallait un peu triché aux caisses des
clc les arbres régulation de self
défense et combat libre au départ on
avait une association et si on allait du
conseil la sauce de combat libre
clairement au japon nous aurait prêté un
créneau original donc j'ai un peu triché
sur le nom mais tant que que les
initiales et sega s'est passé comme ça
pendant des années des années des années
aujourd'hui ça veut plus rien dire parce
qu'en fait on le nom lui-même c'est beau
c'est sdcl causé la salle c'est le
produit de faim dire ce qu'on veut
dessus avec aujourd'hui c'est surtout la
salle sdcl center voit sa puissance on
s'en fout l'origine vraiment juste on
voulait faire du m1 aujourd'hui on a le
droit ça fait deux ans qu'on a le droit
et
voilà on exploite au maximum quoi alors
cet effet quand exactement ce lieu ça a
été créée pour prendre 13 alors ça a été
créé en 2013 en novembre 2013 parce que
donc on à l'origine on était à
coignières au gymnase de coignières
depuis 1997 l époque
on nous donnait un créneau plusieurs
créneaux on a beaucoup beaucoup grossi
et c'est tellement gros cigare au bout
d'un moment en fait on avait pu on avait
pu l'espace nécessaire ne pouvait pas
s'entraîner pendant les vacances pouvait
pas s'entraîner on pouvait pas
s'entraîner port
on pouvait pas s'entraîner pendant les
vacances on n'avait pas le matériel de
musculation nécessaire on a été
restreint et je commence à avoir des
preuves à y ait besoin de plus puis
maraîchers un jeu en bois distant ici
par hasard le local j'ai vu l'espace six
mois il ya un truc de dingue affaire
doit j'avais déjà imaginé des machines à
d'un ring des acquis et voilà j'ai fait
avec une petite économie
j'ai mis toute ma famille sur la paille
voilà
puis je me suis lancé à
nova passion une vraie passion il faut
aujourd'hui enfin clamé enfants qui
traînent là je pense qu'on l'a vu passer
dans le genre
tout le monde fait du mma la maison
depuis plus de 15 mois qui est la bac et
sur le ring
qu'est-ce qui a fait que justement il a
été mordu par le mma je sais pas
l'expliquer je peux pas te dire je ne
sais pas si c'est si c'est san ku kaï ou
si c'est dragon ball au départ je sais
pas
je suis passé par à peu près tous les
sports de combats dans la région à
l'aïkido à maurepas la boxe française et
carlos à l'époque le judo
lutte est en fait en tenant dans les
combats de judo notamment toi je me
retrouver coincé on va peut-être un
contrôle ça dure vingt secondes puis
après tu l'achètes a gagné août a perdu
mémé tu as gagné quoi en fait n'a rien
gagné le combat tant il se relève on
repart j'avais envie d'un truc qu'on va
plus loin et on x la boxe on mixait truc
donc moi j'ai démarré comme ça j'ai
monté un petit asos avec quelques
copains on a fait ça et puis de fil en
aiguille l'autre se sont greffés et puis
j'ai rencontré d'autres personnes en
france qui aimait ça aussi on enfonce
dans le monde et dans l'europe en europe
et puis bah en fait on s'est rendu
compte en fait c'est un vrai sport et on
pouvait le on pouvait le faire monter et
c'est quoi finalement c'est une
reconnaissance peut-être ouais les
instances
histoire du mma finalement qui existe
depuis depuis pas mal d'années un
clermont c'est leurs connaissances et à
c'est un aboutissement alors c'est tu
sais c'est un peu comme le bac le bac
quand tu passes il a assez et c'est en
fait c'est pas c'est pas une finalité
quoi c'est le début d'autre chose utopia
le bac ça tu peux commencer à étudier
apprendre ce que tu as envie d'apprendre
voilà c'est un peu pareil c'est oui ça y
est c'est une reconnaissance mais
maintenant il est tout à faire
maintenant il va falloir montrer au
monde entier qu'on est con et aussi un
pays de combattants on est qu'on sait
faire qu'on a des combattants qui ont
des compétences qui ont des performances
tu as un peu vrai quand même pour que le
mma soit légalisé en france explique
nous oui oui je mens pas je pense avoir
oeuvré en tout cas moi mon niveau à mon
échelle
j'ai fait partie toutes les fédérations
qui ont qui ont été montés deux
fédérations mix sur le but de contact du
guèye combat complet total pancras avec
un risque en classe avec un c'est plus
de contacts d'un dante ou gt gt à des
postes stratégiques dans tous la
commission nationale de m avoir là je
suis pas dans celle là aujourd'hui j'ai
un peu mis de côté le côté fédéral parce
que chacun sait beaucoup
d'investissements c'est beaucoup de
temps et puis je pense qu'il ya des
jeunes aujourd'hui qui peuvent s'occuper
de ça
mais oui on a fait en a fait il en a
montré du mma éducatif on a formé des
enfants j'ai utilisé comme outil de
prévention dans les quartiers notamment
au quartier delà du vally boulez à
l'époque un plaisir croît plaisir en
termes de prévention spécialisée on
utilisait le mma comme outil d'akreuch
pour faire venir les jeunes et les
amener leur autre chose je l'utilisé en
prison je l'utilisé enfin dans un peu
partout ça a été pour moi ça c'est un
vecteur un vecteur d'intégration gl le
sport en général mais le mma par son
côté
interdit vous faites ça a attiré encore
plus aujourd'hui bon bah il est plus
interdit mais tu peux plus allumés
netflix sans tomber sur un film qui
utilise les mêmes à la halle berry qui
vient de sortir un film bon ben voilà
c'est l'ancien combattant de mma il ya
dix ans de sa tuque c'était impossible
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est un
petit peu
les combattants de mma lé des
gladiateurs un peu des temps modernes
c'est ça qui fascine peut-être été un
peu ce sentiment là ouais ouais c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vraiment ça c'est
vraiment ça c'est une telle abnégation
c'est une telle intel
il faut il faut enfin il faut il faut il
faut une fois pour y rentrer dans la
cage là pour se rendre compte de ce que
c'est quand tu rentres que tu faire mais
voilà on est trois dans la case 1 est
allé 2 ya l'arbitré c'est ça ça une
selle c'est autre chose que le cas car
inc bon après n'importe quel combattant
c'est un chien c'est assez un gladiateur
que ce soit en boxe anglaise en
taekwondo qui a pu voir n'importe quoi
pas partie du moulias affrontement il ya
ya ce côté gladiateurs maintenant c'est
un sport abouti qu'on
c'est vraiment ce qu'est ce qui se passe
justement quand on est dans cette cage
se passe
ici on a un adage on dit dans la vie
comme sur le tapis ce qui se passe dans
la cage c'est ce qui se passe dans la
vie cirque à des moments de doute tu as
dès le moment où tu au contraire un
sursaut tu as des moments où t'en peux
plus tu as envie d'abandonner mais tu
peux pas abandonner si tu abandonnes
passé finit donc futur remonte la pente
et tu y retournes et puis un respect de
la diversité
un moment donné on vient pour vraiment
se mettre dessus mais mais quand ces
filles on est deux athlètes et ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est que le club
s'est finalement fait partie de
l'histoire récente du mma il ya
notamment eu à roula soumaré qui a
fréquenté le sdf center qui a été le
premier vainqueur d'un combat mma en
france sas et c'est le premier vainqueur
de combat en france en effet c'est le
premier tout paumé combats sont que
c'était au cirque d'hiver il ya quelques
années et
en effet à l'époque c'est interdit non
c'était pas encore autorisé mais ce
n'était pas encore interdit et
l'organisateur qui est qui n'est autre
que lopez a sonné belle aujourd'hui le
coach numéro un en france il semble
qu'il ait cassé ça dans les cinq
meilleurs coaches du monde celui qui a
qui justement a informé nguyên huu et
diane ce fameux combat c'est lui qui
organisait sa il a eu un peu le courage
de l'organiser en déposant les règles en
août et en anglais parce que c'est des
règles unifiées donc en anglais en août
dans une préfecture française je vois un
peu le truc bon bah tu arrêtes a deux
mois pour répondre après c'est vrai tu
connais un peu le fonctionnement non pas
évidemment personne n'a répondu dans les
temps donc on a pu l'organiser policiers
venus pour interdire mais les avocats et
elle a produit attendait ok mais sur
quelles bases acheter allez vous
regarder qui prenait des notes où ça a
énormément servi et donc oui c'est un
vrai combat avec une vraie kg tout et
c'est plus danger un lieu magnifique le
circle cirque d'hiver c'est vraiment
exceptionnel comme endroit est
dans la question avec toi quel est ton
plus grand rêve pour pour cette salle
pour le sdsl center tu sais mon défaut
je pense je rêve pas pour moi je rêve
pour eux aujourd'hui
moore eux je les les concrétiser g
quand on entend ces deux salles avec ma
femme parce que je n'ai pas dit mais
c'est important c'est aussi parce que ma
femme et la cupule montée en montant
cette salle avec ma femme est
donc j'ai conquis j'ai réalisé moi mon
rêve moi je voulais ça je pense que si
j'avais pas eu ça il y aura un truc il
ya un truc qui courait pas été aboutis
par contre aujourd'hui je rêve pourrait
hélas on en a on en a certains qui
peuvent faire une très grosse carrière
monte très fort et vraiment se réaliser
et ne pas ne pas subir le sixième
victoire c'est se retrouver va faire un
bts qui n'intéressent pas à fermer des
quintés spa est là parce que parce que
parce que vivre un rêve c'est s'investir
mais c'est pas s'investir satis investi
avec les gens j'ai envie de leur donner
cette chance a donc mon rêve c'est que
c'est que c'est que ces jeunes là
arrivent à percer et se faire plaisir et
puis ben après il faudra quelqu'un parce
que bahoken on a fait le boulot mais il
faut pas beaucoup s'arrêtent quoi donc
on va voir mon rêve aussi et pour la
salle j'espère qu'à poids j'espère
surtout que le jour où je suis plus à
ben ça pourra continuer qui aura des
gens pour reprendre et faire faire
fonctionner ce système là on va
maintenant voir les combattants de la
salle
m
[Musique]
alors maxime depuis quand tu vas
commencer le mma toi bats bonjour déjà
moi j'ai commencé mes mains à 25 ans
c'était en 2009 exactement à l'été 2010
9 j'ai commencé je terminais ma saison
de foot et j'ai voulu m'essayer dans le
même alors tu étais footballeur
professionnel a avancé bien ça oui c'est
bien ça j'ai fait plusieurs clubs à
l'étranger en france dont sport-études
quand j'avais 16 ans et qu'est ce qui
t'a fait changer de voie qu'est ce qui
t'a donné envie de faire du mma tu as
peut-être regarder d'aider les combats
la télévision ben j'ai toujours aimé les
sports de combat des arts martiaux et
quand j'étais footballeur je me suis dit
que pourquoi pas un jour essayer et
après l'idée m'est venue de me
reconvertir dans le sport c'est quand
même deux univers complètement différent
on est d'accord franchement c'est très
très différent et ça n'a pas été facile
ses débuts c'était très difficile mais
voilà on s'est adapté et ses débuts
justement dans les mas maxime bas j'ai
fait mes débuts dans mes mains je suis
arrivé j'arrivais dans une autre salle
sur paris de base j'ai fait un mois là
bas mais comme c'était trop loin je suis
venu au sdsl et comme ici c'était très
familial très convivial je restais et
après les entraînements ça s'est bien
passé et exactement un an après quelques
mois après j'ai fait ma première
compétition amateur alors amine toi de
ton côté tu arrivé ou sdsl center très
jeune à l'adolescence à 14 ans je veux
ni c'est en fait je venais de pas de
passeport en fait j'étais vraiment perdu
je vais me chercher je me chercher et
j'ai vraiment apprécié le mma j'ai
commencé à regarder sur youtube etc ça
m'a l'air vraiment excité en fait j'aime
vraiment d'adrénaline le fait que ça
soit un des sports les plus durs ça
change en fait du foot que je faisais
avant j'avais arrêté entre temps mais
voilà j'habitais à trappes et rap
c'était vraiment à côté du sdsl du coup
c'était pratique pour moi mais c'était
en fait le moment où je devais déménager
à bailly et ce moment là bas j'ai kiffé
l'homme bras et j'ai voulu m'inscrire et
je me suis inscrit malgré mon
déménagement donc pour pour rappel bas
et noisy a ici en transport c'est une
heure quarante donc depuis que j'ai 14
ans je fais une heure 40 en trajet pour
venir ici donc même le trajet ce malgré
le trajet ça m'a motivé quand même et
voilà je suis dit combat dix victoires
pour l'instant on reste en amateur est
ce que c'est les objectifs mais j'ai
assez de combats pour passer pro
voilà et qu'est ce qui donne envie
justement de faire au temps de trajet
pour venir ici finalement pour
s'entraîner durement et dans une cage et
peut-être te faire mal c'est celle en
fait c'est le moment de la journée aux
jeux je me ressens en fait je sens que
c'est moi mines et je me lâche en fait
c'est quand il ya un écrivain qui écrit
un livre c'est là où ils peuvent piquer
ses émotions je suis là dans la cage
quand la cage elle est fermée c'est là
où je kiffe en fait c'est mon kiff de la
journée alors tu as commencé à 14 ans
maintenant tu as 18 ans et tu as fait
ton premier combat devant je crois 900
spectateurs un récemment c'est ça
récemment devant 900 spectateurs et
c'était ff13 la nuitée 18 ans la nuit de
mes 18 ans j'avais 18 ans à minuit voilà
et j'ai gagné contre un adversaire qui
était beaucoup plus à âgées comme moi il
avait 27 ans et il avait un bon palmarès
en judo voilà donc malgré ça j'ai pas eu
peur et en avons la foi qu'on a gagné
mais c'est quoi ton ton objectif dans le
mma s'est passé à professionnels
professionnel c'est tombe pas passer
professionnel moi mon objectif l ufc
voilà c'est beaucoup plus grand c'est
c'est la ligue la première ligne que
tout le monde être l'ufc maxime quels
sont tes objectifs à toi bah moi je vous
rejoins de la mine j'ai énormément
d'objectifs dans ce sport et j'aimerais
aussi combats dans des grandes
organisations dont l'ufc qui est le rêve
de tout combattant professionnel et
pourquoi c'est un rêve bah c'est un rêve
parce que j'ai toujours aimé ce sport
même quand j'étais footballeur et je me
donne vraiment les moyens d'arriver à
réussir même si je suis
je suis conscient qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de travail merci à tous les
deux et bon courage pour vos prochains
combats
vous l'aurez compris le mma encore
beaucoup de chemin à parcourir en france
et il y a de plus en plus de licenciés
comme ici où sdcl center c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi le
7-8 sport revient à début janvier pour
deux nouvelles aventures sportives
passer d'excellentes fêtes de fin
d'année et on se retrouve en 2022 belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]